I want to start by saying it's not the
first three episodes I thought they were
great one of the things that I think
people might be surprised is there was
all this talk about how the Apple shows
are gonna be very family-friendly and PG
and no one was sure exactly what was
coming but your show is absolutely rated
R yeah 100%
so could you sort of talk about that
aspect yeah I think you know Apple have
been rightly so they've kept a lot to
their cars to their chests because
people didn't know what to expect and I
think with a show as inventive as this
new with such a new imaginative world
they're gonna give anything away and
you're completely right the show is not
family-friendly in terms of its violent
and it's you cannot put against gore and
love family it's not just like it's not
just the battle stuff it comes up
there's a bunch of stuff but yeah it's a
very visceral show and it's and it's
what I really love about is that it's
based in reality so it's super super
grounded and so there's going to have
like there's going to be all of those
things there's going to be conflict in
every sense there's going to be love
there's going to be a little bit of
nudity so it's just it's it's very
visceral when you feel it and when you
watch it it's it's the same experience I
think yeah one of the things you guys
are twins on the show but you have
completely different personalities talk
a little about that aspects of your
characters um yeah I think it's Steven
wrote a super super well-rounded that
that's I really appreciate the way that
he wrote honey Wonka food because we are
so polar opposite but we kind of have
the same core values we just have
different ways of showing them um honey
hua is obviously a super adventurous she
wants more from life she has the sense
of purpose that she's constantly chasing
but she also really really cares about
family and she loves and respects her
father and her mother just like co foon
does she just has a very teenage girl
way of showing it um Cohen is really
embedded in how Canadian life and
community and family and those are the
kind of values that he holds so dear to
him
you know in an ideal world coven could
have stayed now connealy and the safety
of what that community was for the rest
of his life and shut the secret away and
you know never never tell anybody but
deep in the deepest core he probably
wants more and wants the same things
that you know Hinault has what we were
saying earlier like it's like a tough
exterior and sauce shell and a soft
exterior and then when push comes to
shove it's tough call for him as well
one of the things that I thought was so
well done in the episodes that I saw was
it felt everything felt believable it
felt like this world was just real the
level of production design the
thoughtfulness with the ropes and
everything what was it like stepping on
step for the first time and seeing the
level of detail that had been put
together it was amazing I mean we were
we were in like five weeks before we
started shooting so we were in the
production office and we saw we walked
through the art department and we saw
the sets and we saw things as they were
getting set up and being aged hundreds
and hundreds of years which was I
thought was the coolest part but it's
just it was such a collaborative effort
and everyone was so excited to be a part
of this show and to create this world
together so we felt really well taken
care of Steven great service rewards
straight from the page that's seeing it
like literally before our eyes walking
through the production office it was
insanely exactly what I'd imagined
because he's such a detailed writer and
criticized rich and like the interesting
worlds that I saw it and I might get and
seeing it in front of us was it was
overwhelming and breathtaking and a
dream come true I heard from that you
guys all had a boot camp no did you guys
do the exact same boot camp because your
character is a little different the boot
camp it was ran by the same people but
everyone personalized it based on the
character for us we had the choice
whether we wanted to do it or not we
both participated I didn't go as often
as Archie went because it wasn't on
ongoing thing throughout the show I I
kind of decided to take a step back so I
could feel that little bit of being on
the outside
but it was it's tough it was a tough
thing to go through I when I went more
often than Nestor but you know Nestor
and I have this like real close bond
from the off in real life as well and so
I kind of mirrored Kaufman's experience
of one thing every time Nestor would be
like no go and they'll be like yeah yeah
and then but being like what kind of
want to take part and so I had this
internal struggle the same where they
come from that's like I want to I want
to be with my twin I'm gonna be my
sister but so this is I want to close my
eyes and I want to feel what they're
feeling and like I want to be it's so
funny because this is your character
experiences really murdered them
sometimes out there throughout the show
especially because of this relationship
was so like sibling as I kind of from
the off like it would twitch us out
sometimes out the way that way with this
luck we've really found it to the
characters he's really go into it yeah
too much I would imagine make you
something on this scale and Scout must
have been unbelievable is there like a
dare to that you will always remember
from filming oh man okay I don't want to
give anything away I think that in in
the third episode when they felt that
festival with the big bonfire in the
middle and all of the different tribes
like you had the blue tribe and the ones
in all red and just even the the design
of the priests and everything was just
so well thought out and so built into
the world that was a really really
really fun day for me yeah for me it was
the moment of like wow and we're really
in this was during the slavers sequences
on episode 3 when Co Funes I was on the
floor there were rats literally crawling
around us and I was just looking at this
huge this huge
hundreds of people around me and I was
like wow like we're actually a part of
this world this is at this is all been
pill wait here wait in it this is
incredible and it just it's a bit of a
pity moment no yeah I don't wanna do any
spoilers or anything but I watched
episode three last night and
I will say that there was there's a
moment in that episode where I literally
said out loud holy [ __ ] yeah I was like
really I'm sure you know what I'm
talking about and I can't wait for other
people who are watching the show to see
this can you start to sort of talk about
what is it like reading the scripts for
the first time and you're reading that
because that's oh that's a big moment
mm-hmm um I mean I don't I don't want to
like sound trite by saying excited like
Australian times but it's it's just so
thrilling I love Stephens writing so
much I love how crazy this world is but
like you said feel so real at the same
time so it's just fun I mean I've every
single page I'm like I just can't wait
to find out what's next and the beauty
of a first season as well is everything
is you know being invented Steven could
we literally didn't know what to expect
in the next episode so that we never
come across before something that we you
know one aware that existed in the world
that we lived in and so we were just
always excited always be testing like
the next one it's one like it was
because we just we had that excitement
now as I spread across the board for all
of us we were really exposing to be a
part of it thank you so much
Congrats on the show I can't wait to see
more of it